okay now can you not can you hear me
well I don't know whether this one's
working or not all right so take two
today we are here for a symposium he's
also a practicing physical therapist who
was trained at Pacific University and
he's board-certified in orthopedics and
has a fellowship in manual physical
therapy he is currently a fellow here
and he is also still practicing some a
little bit he's performed research in
psychometrics of patient reported
outcomes tools determinants of
utilization of physical therapy services
and safety of physical therapy
interventions as informatics research
interests are in work behavior and its
impact on the perceptions and
decision-making processes of clinicians
and managers so thank you Chris so thank
you all for taking the time to watch my
presentation today those of you that
aren't familiar with the format this
basically outlines the rationale for my
research interest will do the best kind
of review of the literature right now
and then open up some gaps they've kind
of given me the opportunity to explore
in my research so first I want to start
off by giving you just a frame of what
got me interested in this line of
research so I'm practicing physical
therapists have spent a lot of time the
outcomes world and helping practices
improve their clinical outcomes and I
came to the realization in outpatient
physical therapy clinics many of them
have clinical information systems that
have information that could be used for
managing clinical quality yet they don't
systematically manage that quality in
addition these managers do do a pretty
admirable job of managing their
operational day-to-day things scheduling
revenue these sorts of things but the
management of quality gets kind of
pushed to the side additionally they
spent quite a bit of money on some
systems whether their EHRs whether their
outcomes dashboard systems whether their
registries that they're part of yet
oftentimes they don't use those to make
their decisions based on a clinical
quality up there their clinicians and
specific my interest is in the manager
so most of the research that's done in
clinical quality is on an endline
frontline practitioner and for a good
purpose because those individuals are
providing the care but the manager
serves a special role in there and I'll
kind of outline that through some of the
research as well it's really this led me
to four main clinical questions so these
research questions would be one what
stakeholder values influence managers
decision-making relative to their
operation one clinical management so
really there's lots of stakeholders in
the healthcare world
how do those values shape what the
managers choose to manage second would
be what questions do the managers have
an outpatient PT practices when they're
trying to manage the clinical quality
this hasn't been studied at all so what
a managers need to know so that they can
be more effective managers of quality
third would be what our organizational
facilitators and barriers exist that
would influence these managers use of
health information technology to answer
their questions so again these companies
have spent lots of money on these
systems yet managers and frontline
practitioners don't use them or
certainly don't use them to their
fullest capacity and then the last one
would be what context these contextual
factors that we speak up here
how do those influence constructs that
can also predict use of information
technology so we know from some models
that I'll share that individuals are
compelled or blocked from using
information technology by a myriad of
factors so how do contextual factors
play into that mix so kind of a big
question my research interest really
spans three huge areas that any one of
them by themselves could be a research
dissertation so quality and value is
clearly important especially as we move
to this fee for value model in all of
healthcare but I'm more interested in
how do we use as an informatics issed
how do we use information technology in
that world of managing quality and value
but more than that I'm more interested
in how does organizational behavior
shape one's use of information
technology for the purpose of clinical
quality so really my area of research
interests lives in
that little sliver over on the side here
certainly touching on quality but it's
really focusing on this interface
between organizational behavior and use
of information technology and
specifically managers doing that so
that's where this is a bit unique from
the research out there is I'm interested
in the managers role in use of
information technology more so than the
frontline individual so take a step back
and see where we are in the healthcare
landscape now and quality or value we've
moving from a fee-for-service history to
a what's called a fee for value future
and really the biggest indicator of that
in the here and now is CMS is pushed to
the mips program so the merit-based
incentive payment system so this takes
the quality initiatives that CMS has
been pushing for years and puts them
under one umbrella and what this does is
providers are still paid fee-for-service
but then they receive a a either a bonus
or a reprimand for using or not using
this quality measures in a good way
the interesting thing is we use quality
and value interchangeably but they're
not the same thing there was a study
that's studied by hew see it all took 61
studies that looked at clinical quality
this is an all of medicine and they
looked at were those did those relate
with to improved cost and they found
roughly a third of those studies showed
that the cost was slightly better or
better a third of those said there was
no change and a third of those said
actually cost more so the moral the
story is higher quality doesn't
necessarily relate to higher value if
you use money as your measure of value
conversely this other study here is a
Cochrane Collaboration that looked at
the use of shared decision-making aids
specifically with patients and how they
make their to see their treatment
decisions and it did find that patients
that use shared decision-making aids
were to be a component of quality did
have more confidence in their decisions
and also it it resulted in less
healthcare spend on those patients that
use those tools so depend on how you
define quality it may actually relate to
value and certainly that takes us to the
next slide would be well what's the
definition of quality and really that is
in the eye of the stakeholder and some
of the research down here has done a
decent job of breaking up who are the
biggest stakeholders and how
CAIR world and they're thoroughly the
patient the provider the manager the
organization itself payers and I'll talk
about more that in a moment and then
also public health and policy makers so
this first in the the perspective of
each of these individuals is not
completely unique from the other group
there's a lot of overlap here but in
general patients tend to focus more on
service quality and you can either
relate this to quality like in retail or
quality in your dining experience so
there's been measures of the translate
to both medicine and these other service
industries and there was this other
study by Lee did show that Wow
patients do focus on that quality piece
like the retail type quality they also
are cognizant of the skill of the
provider and the outcome that they get
so it is it's a little overly simplistic
to say it's only on service quality the
provider certainly is focused on
technical quality whether that's picking
the right intervention or doing the
intervention that they picked well but
additionally they live in this mediator
role that they are the arbiter of the
health care dollar
and so they while they have to get their
patient better and they're through a
shared decision-making arrangement
understand the patient's needs and help
them achieve those goals they also have
to be a a good steward of that
healthcare dollar the manager will come
back to you because they live in a very
middle role here and that's part of the
reason I've selected them as someone to
focus on the organization itself has to
both serve its customer which is equal
part patient as well as payer so you
have to know the patient's needs you
have to know the payers and minions and
you have to live the bridge between
those but you also have the
organization's need the orders they can
ask to survive and thrive and so that's
a player in it as well and then you have
the public health policymakers that
really are more looking at health care
equity proactive screening prevention
and disease that sort of thing but if we
come back to this manager the manager is
kind of the middleman that has to play
in all these worlds and in fact one of
these studies looked at how well a
provider could could understand the
patient's perspective versus how well a
manager could understand a patient's
perspective and in fact the manager was
a better a liner and underst
the perspectives of the patient better
than the provider did potentially
because there one person removed they're
not as conflicted but it did show that
at least that manager has a special role
in the quality arrangement and kind of
mediating between all of the
stakeholders so you may have seen this
chart as we try to look for how do we
fix the healthcare spin Porter and Lee
did come out with this kind of model
that they say would would fix healthcare
in fact the title of the article is the
strategy that will fix healthcare and
while I think it's it is good and it
touches on a lot of areas that need to
be changed
I'll argue that it may be a little bit
simplistic as well but basically what it
says not simple or easy but overly
simplistic so basically what it says is
that you have at the top we need to
break down silos so rather than having a
patient go to a primary care
practitioner and if they have cancer
let's say they go to an oncologist then
they go to radiologists then they go to
a surgeon maybe they go to some sort of
a therapist to help them they're bounced
around rather than doing that you you
create these integrated practice units
that treat the patient where they are so
a team atmosphere
additionally collecting outcomes on all
patients you can't change what you're
not measuring so the recommendation is
to measure these outcomes measures
regularly move to a bundled payment
system so move out of this fee for
service system altogether and just pay
for bundles of care may help break that
integrating systems so this was really
what we strive to do in informatics a
great deal is to connect the disparate
system so you can share information from
one facility to another and then also
expanding services across geographies so
can you have specialists at an academic
Medical Center like the HS you spend
some time in tertiary centers in rural
areas to share the skill level and don't
just house it in one metropolitan area
orderly argue that if you do all of that
and you wrap it in an enabling
technology system then this is really
what makes the faint hum now I say it's
overly simplistic is you look at all
these they're very structural if you do
these things then care will get better
but the problem is care is delivered by
individuals all of whom live in a
ever-changing world that shapes their
decision making
and so most of us in informatics are
familiar with this this fundamental
theorem of informatics that basically
says an individual thinking plus a
computer would give us a better decision
than the individual on our own again I
say that's probably a bit overly
simplistic because if we look at this
this is called Leavitt Dimond and this
is basically the first crack at looking
at a socio technical system and this
says that the computer and the
individual which are represented here
they are in a system that has a certain
structure and have a certain task that
they're doing in the task and structure
and the individual and Technology all
relate to one another to really impact
what that outcome is going to be so you
can't just say if you give a amazing
computer system to an amazing clinician
you're gonna get an even more amazing
outcome it is really shaped by the
structure of the organization and the
task of here in the informatics world
this has been up to a little bit so
sitting and colleagues looked at this
eight step socio-technical model and
this was really looked at with respect
to implementation of health IT into
hospital systems and the risks that come
with that and the failures of of
implementations but really it could be
extrapolated to this use of information
technology in an ongoing system as well
and really what it says is you have
information that's contained inside of
software that's run on hardware that
hardware is interface to an individual
through a interface those individuals
work in systems that they communicate
with other people and have certain
workflows those are all wrapped inside
an organization that has policies
procedures and its own culture you wrap
all of that in the measurements that the
organization puts on that work on itself
and then also external rules and
regulations that kind of push on the
outside and this this model was actually
validated by Leakes and his group that
that did look at 12 Hospital
implementations in the UK and looked for
risks that came with an implementation
or failures in the implementation and
they could take all those down to being
related to one of these eight areas so
at least on the face it makes sense that
the failures that we see in technology
news and implementation that's in one of
these world
but I want to call out is this one that
didn't even get its own icon up here so
all the other ones got nice little icons
but the one stuck in the middle or sorry
on the side organizational policies
procedures and culture really is the
wrapping and the glue that holds all
these pieces together so the culture of
your organization will shape workflows
and communication that shapes how
individuals interface with their systems
and this area of organizational culture
especially is really the purview of our
managers our managers are really good at
setting stages to help implement the
organizational policy that starts to
come down they have to get that out to
the masses they have to hear what the
frontline clinicians are saying and take
that back up so they really are a
referee if you will in the in a
healthcare organizational culture world
so there are some studies that have
looked at what is the role of a manager
in healthcare there's not a ton of these
studies this one was from hospital CEOs
so they asked executives of hospitals
what are the role of their managers and
really they broke it down in these
levels of certainly they have to manage
day-to-day things all the stresses that
come with day-to-day operations more
than that though their analysts so they
have to look and find where there are
potential problems when they find
problems they're going to be
intervention selectors so they have to
identify maybe what's something that you
should try to change that to make change
there are also designers of the
intervention so not only do they have to
see the problem and recommend a solution
but they also have to design what that
solution might be or at least
participate in that process they
implement it so even if the organization
says you're going to do this it's
oftentimes the manager who has to
implement that change to the
organization so in that their change
leaders they have to not just give
something to the masses and say good
luck go after it they have to help you
that process of change leadership and
then also they are evaluators so once a
change initiatives happen or some
intervention was done they are really
tasked with gathering the information to
see was it effective or not in addition
to that these other studies added to
this list to say there are also
communication facilitators so they
really help the interpersonal
communication between the day-to-day
providers and all those
the organization also trust agents so
they really help with that interpersonal
relationship that really nurtures trust
and that trust is what helps teams grow
and so they have to be the agents to
kind of nurture that an organization as
well as assimilation agents and this
assimilation agent really touches on the
informatics world so you can have an
organization that says we're going to do
this and we think it's the best thing in
the world and they may even message it
very well but those individuals the
managers are responsible for ensuring
that that message and that Y gets down
to the masses that training gets
percolated down to the individuals that
need it and they are really helping get
that all the way through the
organization so it doesn't get
bottleneck from top it's stuck getting
down to the bottom of the organization
and this strikes me with a couple of
books I'm not sure if any of your read
views but this predictably irrational by
Dan Harley and they aren't Sunstein's
nudge this speaks to anybody read this
book these are great books they speak
they're basically behavioral economics
but they speak to the fact that
individuals decisions are actually a
product of the environment in which they
made that decision and so this has
really been a motivating factor in my
interest in this area to say that you
can have a great information system the
world's best information system and you
can have very willing providers who want
to use that system but if the context
within which they operate isn't
conducive to them using a system then
they won't use the system conversely you
can have a horrible system and people
are somewhat unwilling but if you kind
of tweak and massage the environment a
bit you can get them to make decisions
that you like based on these contextual
factors that you we've shaped for them
and so this is really my interest in
taking the managers role in doing that
and pushing that to the informatics
world specifically in quality so I'll
take a step back here and look at
communication and trust and we'll start
to get in some regression models so this
is going to get into a little bit of
math but pretty pretty simple but what I
want to do with this is show one how I
plan to use some models on prediction of
IT use but also show how trust and
communication influence interpersonal
relationships in an organization
so the Sarkar study looked at basically
they looked at a net a network approach
so social network to find out
individuals that were in the center of a
trust circle so lots of people trusted
them or people that were in the center
of a communication circle so a lot they
communicated with lots of people versus
being on the periphery or maybe they
were only trusted by one or two people
are communicating with one of three
people their hypothesis was people in
the center that were really trusted by a
lot and communicated with a lot that
would predict their peers review of
their performance of their work so those
trusted people and communicative people
were seen as higher with their skill
level they also know wanted to look at
is there potentially a mediating effect
so could communication be mediated by
trust so yes communication could predict
whether a person is seen as having good
performance but maybe Trust mediates
that or third they looked at what about
trust as a moderating factor so you do
an interaction term between trust and
communication and see is that a better
predictor of individual practice so they
looked at all three of these using
hierarchical regression models and what
they found was this first one putting
trust in communication which we all
would agree are necessary for your peers
to think they're doing a good job or
it's contribute accounted for about 66%
of the variation in individual
performance so pretty decent in
organizational behavior predictions the
interesting thing they found though was
Trust was much much better in fact it
was very significant where communication
wasn't really predicted at all so taken
on a surface you'd say if you trust a
person but if they never talk to you
he's still going to say they did a good
job by contrast they looked at
communication mediated by trust to ended
or individual performance it got to the
same predictive level but the
interesting thing when they looked at
just communication on its own it was
about 41% predictive of individual
performance but when you put the
mediator in the middle of which
communication is a pretty decent
predictor it only got it back to the
same level up here so Trust fully
mediated communication the interesting
thing to me is this one up here when
they looked at trust as a moderating
effect here's where you got the best
predictive value and in fact what they
found here was the negative trust was
the most
addictive so a person who you really
didn't trust even if they were really
central in the communication world they
were not seen as very individually
productor they didn't have great
performance individually they're kind of
just a clanging cymbal that no one
trusted so really I show this up here
because for two factors one to show that
managers need to be trusted and that
trust that their their followers have in
them directly relates to the
communication strategy but additionally
as I start to show some models on the
prediction of IT use where you put in
these predictive factors into the model
will have an influence on filfil altima
power of the model and specifically the
role of mediators or if we think of
context in which we put these decisions
maybe those contextual factors are
really strong moderating factors on the
overall model and we'll talk more about
that so really the case of why choose
physical therapy for this physical
therapy is an interesting practice one
I'm a practicing physical therapist so I
know more about it than other areas of
Medicine but the interesting thing is
physical therapy wasn't included in the
meaningful use processes so all of the
health IT in there especially the
outpatient physical therapy world was
not borne by incentives but has just
been kind of a grassroots organic
process because of that there's a lot of
different systems out there and uptake
is really being great in some and
horrible and others because there aren't
standards like maybe meaningful use
incentive pushed in a hospital system
say in addition the PBRs measures so
those quality measures that that the
healthcare system has been accountable
for for the last few years only a very
small sliver of those pqrs measures
relate to physical therapy so when they
were doing those measures they either
picked a few of them the only few that
they could take or they chose not to
pick them at all and just take the
penalty that the pqrs system put on them
just because the systems weren't there
for the measures we're not very
meaningful to physical therapists in
addition the MIPS program that I talked
about early that merit-based incentive
program that's just now starting in the
physical therapy world 2019 will be the
first time that they are even capable
and they will off the
2020 and probably more likely 2022 will
be when they really start to hit this
and now is really a timely place for a
physical therapist to understand how
they get engaged with quality before
they get hit with these systems mandated
by the government also with respect to
quality physical therapy has its own
issues relative to how we provide care
so if we look at low back pain that
accounts for roughly forty percent a
little more than forty percent of all
cases that come to outpatient physical
therapy of that care less than fifty
percent of it is guideline in hearing
and this is regardless of the fact that
there's some very good clinical practice
guidelines for low back pain in physical
therapy that have been around since the
late 90s that have gone all the way down
to comparative effectiveness research
that says if you do this not only will
you get a better outcome in the
short-term but it will save you
significant money in the long run even
downstream savings and this is pervasive
in physical therapy but it's less than
fifty percent to care when measured even
at organizations that are gospel in
doing it it's still not done by
frontline facts and collisions so
there's some other changes that need to
happen and when you ask the clinicians
why don't they use clinically why don't
they do clinically guideline adherence
care the biggest predictors are burden
to them or they don't feel that the
guidelines are relative to their
patients there's a lot of personal
personal feeling about it there's not a
lot of organizational push if we lift it
up outside of the physical therapy world
and we look at just information-seeking
so how do practitioners look for
information and ask questions
Delfy all did a systematic review of a
bunch of papers that looked at
physicians questioning and they found
there's less than a 60 percent answer
rate or put differently each physician
typically generates a question for
basically every two patients you get one
question for two patients on the average
of those roughly 60% are pursued to try
to find an answer and of those roughly
70% they do they find an answer to so
when you work it all out it's less than
60% are the questions that are created
do they ever get an answer and when you
look at what predicts whether
we'll go and seek that answer ultimately
find it really it has to do with
physicians don't trust that they could
find the answer and specifically they
don't trust they could find the answer
in a timely fashion
so some of that has to be with a
technology some of that may have to do
with training but some of that may have
to do with the context within which
they're making those decisions limited
engagement of quality metrics so this
2012 study looked at what percentage of
those PQRS measures were used by
physical therapists and dependent on the
organization it's between four and fifty
one percent so some organizations have
said we're not going to even use those
measures because it's too burdensome for
us to even collect them the penalty is
worth less to us than what we make on
administrative savings not engaging them
so it's too burdensome we're not going
to do that and like I said those pqrs
measures is only so few of them even
relate to physical therapy they don't
have other measures to pick like in
medicine you have a laundry list of
measures you could pick to find value
physical therapy doesn't have as many in
addition when polled organizational
leaders when they pull what is the role
of the manager order top skills that a
manager needs to have quality management
is not even listed as one of the top
five skills for a manager it really is
operational efficiency communication
those sorts of things quality management
doesn't make the list so managers are
asked to manage quality but when hired
they're not hired with that trait and
they're also not probably given the
support structure to manage those
systems well we'll talk about that more
later and then finally the information
systems for a physical therapy is
different than in medicine so there's
been a lot of study the city model that
I showed up earlier talks about hospital
care there's been a less but at least
some look at information systems and
outpatient physician world there's been
very little look at information systems
in the PT world and they use systems
much different in position we don't do
orders so you can't use a lot of the
CPOE another clinical decision support
that has an alert trigger based on an
order in addition there's a variety of
different homegrown systems they're not
congealing around one main system like
we are in the epic world there's still
just a myriad of different systems that
adds variety
and there's also very few outcome
systems and registry there are a few
they're expensive and systems are people
are actually buying them or
organizations do purchase them but
they're not getting used they're
spending a lot of money on these systems
and just sitting there not actually
managed in Bailey Argos in the beginning
so really why does this all matter how
does this relate to really my my end
game wanting to know how context affects
use of IT and managing quality there has
been this is a hospital-based studies
these two studies down here did look at
organizations and what percentage of
organizations actually had bodies in
them that were focused just on quality
and roughly 50% of the 60% that
responded there's probably a selection
bias here but roughly 50% of the
hospitals that were queried said yes we
have a board that is tasked with or at
least a major part of our guiding bodies
meetings are tasked with looking at
outcomes or looking at quality down one
level
what percentage looked at actually
having some dashboard or some some hard
measures that they look at national
benchmarks on a regular basis
that's roughly 60 to 70 percent of those
organizations so of those 50 percent 60
to 70 percent of them use some sort of a
dashboard to be able to make their
decisions that's done even though these
both these studies looked at those
hospitals that hired ACO scores so that
our quality if you wanted to find it as
that they did find difference as a
significantly significant significantly
more of the higher performing
organizations use dashboards than those
that didn't now this was in the
inpatient setting we're probably use of
health IT is better than in the
outpatient setting and I could say that
because if you look at the hims mram
scores so those you don't know the hem
around scores look at how an
organization uses their information
systems and it's a seven-point scale at
level 5 is basically where physicians
have to start doing structured entry so
they use pick lists and it's it's kind
of that level where we're starting to
really hum in the system hospital
systems about 73 percent of em are at
level 5 6 or 7 if we do the outpatient
side only 40 percent so outpatients
still lags way behind the hospital so if
this system has seen
hospitals where they're not using
technology to make their decisions we
can only infer that it's going to be
worse than the outpatient setting but
this is one of the holes it hasn't been
studied to look at how to outpatient
organizations and if their quality
that's part of the reason I'd like to
study it okay so what I want to go into
next and this is kind of the heart of
where I'd like to go with my research is
we take all of that quality is an issue
managers need to manage quality and
they're not doing it physical therapy is
a good use case but now we want to look
at technology and specifically what
factors will predict whether a person is
going to use technology because an
organization can can impact the actual
use of the system by changing some of
these predictive factors down here so
these models that I'm going to show you
there's a bunch of them I'm going to
show you just two a third one at the end
these models have been validated what
they use is structural equation modeling
and then take these latent variables of
attitudes towards the behavior and
subjective norms for this one something
you can't measure directly and what they
do is use a survey to with validated
questions that they can then say alright
those questions relate to this and then
we can measure how those factors or
those constructs influence the behavior
down the in most of them are built off
of this theory of reasoned action this
is a psychological sociological model
that basically says if you want a person
to do something or a targeted behavior
you walk it backwards and that person
should probably have some intention to
do it so if I want to walk out the door
I should think that walking out the door
is a good idea my attitude is that I
think walking out the door is a good
idea if the people around me think it's
also a good idea I put those two
together that's going to make me want to
do it and then I'll actually do it that
model you'll see in all of these these
models that I show you and there's a
bunch of antecedents are these
predictive factors that can lead to that
down the road so this it was back in
1989 it was not boring computer use but
it's been tested to see how predictive
of computer use could it be and what
they showed was basically attitude
towards the behavior coupled with
subjective norms accounted for about 26%
of the variance in intention and if they
could measure the intention
to use that predicted about 40% of the
news of the of the actual system the
point to that I want to make here is
that this one is much more predictive
than that's that one if we just look at
the beta is subjective norm isn't even
significant when we look at this if you
drop it out this r-squared doesn't drop
significantly
and so really attitude towards the
behavior seems to be the biggest
predictor is what this says
now I'll remind you as we go through a
couple models remember that this
subjective norm didn't look to be
predictive right here it's not that it's
bad but if we go back to the moderating
factor that I showed you in the
communication and the trust model a
little earlier maybe it's in the wrong
place maybe we have to put it somewhere
else and see its impact
they just didn't study that here the
technology acceptance model Tam this is
a very pervasive model in the study of
implement earth attitudes towards use of
AI the IT and even health IT so if we
compare that to what we just saw this
attitude towards using is the same
attitude towards using right here
what Tam did was they said can we
predict this a little bit better we'll
get rid of subjective norm and just take
it out and we'll say can we predict this
and see how well that action predictions
and it actually does a little bit better
so perceived usefulness is basically I
think this system is going to make my
job easier or I think by using this
system I'm gonna get a better outcome
versus perceived ease of use I think
it's a really good system I think it's
really easy to use you put those two
together they can predict about 36% of
the variation which is very significant
towards the attitude but the interesting
thing here is then the attitude is only
as small and not even a statistically
significant predictor of the actual
behavior between attitudes and perceived
usefulness we can actually predict 51%
of their intention to use the IT system
but the biggest predictor by far is
perceived usefulness or put another way
the person can think the system is
actually horrible and think the system
doesn't work well at all but if they
think the system is useful for their
work or in the end it will give them
some benefit then they'll actually use
the system and this will be important as
we look at the the next model they took
this cam into a third model this is
important because this
attitude piece used to be a really
strong predictor it was born out of the
theory of reasoned action back here that
attitude was gonna mediate everything
else but what they found this one is
attitude really wasn't as important as
how useful they thought the system was
going to be for them even if they
thought the system itself was a bad
system this one makes us take pause
because the implementers world does a
lot of user centered design studies we
try to make our systems really useful to
the individual this makes my point that
even we need to do that and that's
probably predictive but that may not be
the most predictive of whether they're
going to actually want to use the system
the perceived usefulness piece and how
you message that and how your world is
shaped around your technology actually
may be a much bigger predictor than the
attitude itself and that's shown big
difference between the beta they have
studied this in health IT in a few
different studies and so the intention
to use actually is pretty similar to
what they found in this original study
and their actual IT use is anywhere from
12 to 62% which is in the ballpark of
the 40% that they saw so now I'm going
to show you where this world has gone
this the theoretical model building
especially 19 use has kind of been a an
exercise in who can make the best model
and we'll just make a new model for the
sake of making a new model so there's
lots of models that cropped up I'll show
you the list of a few and it seems like
when a new model crops up gets one
degree separate from the next model and
everyone's just trying to be 2% more
predictive than the one before
so this is the third version of Tam and
you'll see here it's got perceived
usefulness that I showed you in the last
one sees these at use they took the
attitude out because it wasn't
predictive and they now have that
behavioral intention and use it's the
same model here with attitude removed
but then what they did as I said can we
find all these predictors of these
things and now they started to introduce
the idea of modifiers and what they
found was this tool is slightly better
and like I say one 1 degree better than
Tam 2 but a hundred degrees more complex
right because if you remember how we
measure these is each one of these
constructs has probably three to six
questions that a person has to be asked
in a survey so now we add these up and
we're in the order of 80 to 90 questions
it would have to go to the individual
entities in addition to any other
questions you're trying to study but
what this did show is that this yellow
one experience was a huge moderator all
the studies prior to this looked at
consumer so would you use my cell phone
and you're not obliged to use it but in
in an organization you either are
mandated to use a system or you've used
a system for years and so your intention
to use a system may change based upon
more experience that you have and so
what they found here was this experience
moderated nearly every other factor if
they take this out the model was not as
predicted they put it in and it affects
how things like personal factors
influence perceive if we the experience
the person has with that system is
moderated by their experience and then
we have contextual factors also
moderated we have sociological factors
for that subjective norm that I showed
you on the theory of reasoned action it
wasn't really predictive of use of a
system actually up here is shown to be a
pretty strong moderator as well it has
some influence as a predictor of
personal usefulness so those people
around you thinking it's a good idea
does have an ultimate influence on this
but it's mediated by a couple of other
factors but all of this should show it
gets one complex but also shows that
this effective moderation starts to seep
into this world and this is the area
that intrigued me as its effect modifier
and then we also have the system factors
themselves live up here
so Weber and colleagues did look at what
makes up a good model of health IT what
could predict health IT use and really
they came up with five factors so
certainly the the system should be able
to it should be important to touch
something that's important to the world
we shouldn't look at use of the Palm
Pilot right now because no one uses the
Palm Pilot right now but maybe iPhone
would be a good one novelty so this the
model should be significantly different
than the other models it's trying to
replace again this back-and-forth
shuffling of trying to
one model two degrees better than
another probably isn't useful there has
to be a meaningful difference is making
sure the model is parsimonious or the
Occam's razor idea that the simplest
model is probably the best model still
holds maybe it's not exclusively the
simplest model but if you have two that
are equally predictive or close and one
is much simpler you'd probably pick the
more simple model and then level it
shouldn't be so hyper-focused on one
piece of technology that that model
can't be expanded to use in other
settings so it has to have external
generalizability and then it also has to
be falsifiable you can't just make a
model and then that's untestable so the
model should be testable to see through
they actually predict what they say
they're going to predict so this is the
laundry list of the models that are out
there there's more but these are the
main ones so we have a theory of reason
maximum can we talked about there's a
motivational model that looks at where
you whether you're internally motivated
or externally motivated they looked at
theory of planned behavior which
basically took that motivational model
and plugged it in with theory of
reasoned action they put tam and theory
of planned behavior together and there's
a few others all of these models
together though Venkatesh and his
colleagues did a great thing in about
2012 he's basically said all of these
models together probably have some
common constructs and can we simplify
them all down to common constructs and
so what he broke it down to was there's
probably an element of performance
expectancy or how useful the system is
going to be for me there's a measure of
effort expectancy or how easy a system
to use there's some sort of a social
influence and there's some amount of
facilitating conditions that the
organization puts on use of that system
that either encourages are dissuading
from using the system took those four
things together and they said you start
that at the core and all the other
models basically then just either try to
add these what they call exogenously
isms which would predict the predictors
basically or there might be a missed
predictor down here that you could add
in or again in my area of interest is
were there other moderating effects that
the model itself is pretty decent but
could you add moderating effects to make
the model better so that's where they
all kind of live
live together and if you look at the
unified theory of noose and acceptance
I'd tease their youth out I won't say
that long thing again so you Tao is what
this is called they added their own
survey questions that have been
validated to predict these constructs
and when you feed that into use of
information technology based on the
study down here between 52 and 77
percent predictive of the variance in
use or sorry the intention to use and
then 41 to 67 percent predictive award
and explains the variance in the
technology used forty-one sixty seven
seven percent so significantly better
than the Tam model the complex Tam
Oliver showed earlier and really what
the influence that they added the big
difference is is they added in gender
experience age and voluntariness so
whether you should use a system or not
as there's moderating factors that was a
big change and then additionally they
looked at these facilitating conditions
and this is the interesting thing to me
that yes this is strongly predicted this
beta is definitely more than that data
but this is still a significant beta
which taken another way would say even
if a person has no intention to use the
system if you put facilitating
conditions around them
they still might use the system even
though they never intended to use it or
another way they have every intention to
use the system but if you put all these
organizational conditions around them
competing priorities make it really hard
to use everyone bad-mouths the system
then they won't use a system even though
everything else in them said I should
use the system to me that's really
intriguing and a lot of these things are
the predictors of those because they're
moderating effects and this really
speaks to the idea of context so context
being situational opportunities and
constraints that affect other the other
measures or basically things in your
relationships your job roles that will
modify the impact of one variable on
another variable and really again what
I'm interested in is this moderation of
context factors down here and so
Venkatesh in their 2006 work said really
the context could be divided into these
external high-level contextual factors
those are factors of the organization
things like their attributes their
organization structure their change
management strategy their leadership
our key location attributes so in one
organization two different locations
that have different cultures how does
that influence the model and then I'm
really interested in these task
attributes so how do you apply the model
now in the caste of a manager managing
equality the task itself may actually
influence how the model predicts the
same model put in a different task may
behave entirely differently so in
physical therapy this has been used a
bit only two studies one study was
actually done on occupational therapy
which for all of you out here is
different than physical therapy so and
what they did find they tried to make
their own model so they were one of
those that said youth out is good but
I'm going to tweak it just a little bit
make it my own just for ot so they used
implementation issues technology issues
and individual issues which contain the
constructs of you kow but they jumble
them a bit and they looked at moderators
but their moderators were really just
age gender experience skill level and
location what they found was these
moderators didn't have a really huge
impact on the prediction of these other
things but when these things moderated
one another they actually did have an
impact so again they were interested in
looking at moderating effects and their
impact on whether a person intended to
use any system the other nuance here is
this was do you use any technology at
all in any of occupational therapy in
any setting so it's really wide so
really rock with the potential for some
unmeasured confounders and then one
other study looked at PT and ot together
and had decent R Squared's for
prediction of use and actual abuse but
they didn't study the moderating effects
overall interesting thing is when they
looked at people not using the system or
why don't you use a system they surveyed
them most people said expect that I
don't have time to use it I need more
training I don't have the right patience
but the interesting thing is they only
saw 43 sorry 4 percent of them said it
was those facilitating factors were
important whereas if you look at this
the beta's for the facilitating
conditions were actually significantly
higher than behavioral intention for
these individuals again put another way
they didn't intend the use system but if
they had the right facilitating
conditions they would still use it or
vice versa but even though that's the
case the reality
people that they measure their
perception was I don't use it because I
don't have time so this has to be
measured it can't just be maybe an
ethnographic study that you just ask
them two questions you may actually have
to measure it on the back end that's why
I'm interested as I go through the last
of my aims using a mixed model approach
so I'm interested for one aim and a gap
in the literature would be I'd like to
understand the information needs and
seeking behaviors of these managers when
they're quality doing quality management
so what do they need to know and that
has to be done with a brown Theory
ethnographic approach because there are
no theories and models on this right now
so I'm interested in developing some
things from using what's called rapid
and ethnography which is just an
iterative approach a team-based approach
that would allow us to build theories
quickly test those theories quickly and
refine them iteratively with a group and
sampling PT practices in the US that
represent kind of the disparate types of
settings for outpatient PPE second I be
interested in knowing what are those
contextual factors that will influence
the behavior of the manager using or not
using their information systems to
manage quality so specifically take if
you use your system what contributes to
that or what does and then again using
ethnography to build models these will
give me those contextual factors that
I'd like to use to then test on the
model and then the last bit would be
taking the new top model putting in
these factors that we found from a 1 and
2 and seeing how those can influence
their use of either their intention to
use their system in the near future to
manage quality or maybe their
satisfaction with the system that they
use now not one system am i interested
in it's just using the system that you
have
and then finally independent variables
could be the you top factors themselves
the contextual factors that I add in or
potentially those moderating factors
that have already been tested in other
studies gender and experience and again
this could be done via survey about
patient managers so last bit just
recognize my funding sources so I'm part
of my work is funded by the foundation
for physical therapy in addition to the
NLM training grant and to thank my
advisor so far that have helped in this
process so Joe and Karen
and Paul as well as a net and kind of
designing this thank you Chris so now so
now I would like to open it up for
questions
all right thank you very much can you
hear me okay yeah right I really
appreciate this this is this is really
interesting stuff you've got it seems to
me like so much of this is dependent
upon how the questions are phrased and
like in terms of facilitating I can
think of as an explanation as to why
there was such a big gap somebody said
why aren't you doing this I don't have
enough time leadership is not
facilitating this by giving me enough
time to to do it or enough training so
that would be one way to look at it and
another way facilitation could mean the
leadership just doesn't think it's that
important or you know that's just not
been a thing that the managers have
recommended or pursued so how do you do
this going forward to standardize this
approach and try and eliminate that bias
and get to the results you're looking at
facilitating conditions especially in
physical therapy have never been
established so when you don't have
theory established you need to use some
qualitative approaches to develop that
theory first and so that's where those
first two points are aimed at is what
things do you feel our facilitators and
barriers to using systems what are the
questions you actually have so that we
can ask does the system actually help
you answer those questions so those
factors can be created and kind of
refined in the qualitative piece in the
form of themes but to your point the way
that this structural equation modeling
works so they use partially Squared's
it's the way that they typically do this
so you take three to five questions to
represent that latent variable and then
you can run it through the model and
find out similar to if you use the
chromebox alpha you want to know which
how related all of those are together or
how much the variance can be explained
by one of those factors together so we
can take those and put them into a model
in the model tells if that's a good
question that is predictive of the
others then it stays in if not you can
take it out so that's part of this now I
will also say my goal is not to create a
new theory I want to use the TAM based
theory and then add just a few other
factors so to your point the questions
that they ask I'm sorry you taught not
the Utah questions that they used have
already been validated I'm not
questioning whether those are good or
bad I'm just saying take the questions
that you already took and I'm interested
in how does the organizational context
at a task context change whatever result
that gave you for good or for that yeah
so it for me it makes it a little easier
because they don't care whether they're
good or bad questions I care
they've already been validated so I know
they're at least decent I want to know
do these other factors influence them
thanks Chris that's great um you you
mentioned there's some difference in
perception of what are factors and
measurements of what might actually be
factored the organizational context
might be really susceptible to that or
catch those sort of disparities yeah so
especially in the ethnographic piece
that's where you have sampling issues if
I'm trying to make sure that as I sample
organizations I get the broad swath of
what is outpatient physical therapy so
you can have a 1 PT practice in Iowa is
much different than a hospital based
system in Portland Oregon so we want to
make sure that as the Duty ethnographic
piece we get samplings from all of those
and then we compare themes that were
generated individually are there some
overarching themes that seem to really
resonate with all of them or do we find
that actually the small practices have
something that really looks different
or the academic medical centers have
something that really looks different
that we want to test out in the survey
then in the survey I can sample for that
reason but I think you're onto something
that a practice isn't the practices into
practice so hopefully my ethnographic
sampling helps in the beginning to get
kind of a broad-based set of theories
but the sampling will have to be
stratified to account for that
so I'm a little bit confused about the
logical type by that I mean I can't tell
when I hear about these theories of
adoption of Technology about whether
they're talking about an organization
adapting a technology or the individual
choosing a technology yeah
it seems to me especially in large
organizations where technology is
adopted and implemented and so forth and
especially in healthcare it's not clear
to me who's making the choices and
therefore what functioning at and
whether we sometimes apply approaches
that were developed for individual
decision making to organizational
decision languages yes a great point and
so this is these have all been designed
at the individual level so will an
individual use the system or not the the
addition of the voluntariness on that
tam 3 is really an important one so in
an organizational setting you may be
obliged to use because it's the only
system you have and if you don't use it
you don't work here
so that's added into that now now it
becomes non predictive if everyone's
required to use it but I think in the
manager using an information system
there have been a couple not in the
healthcare world but in manufacturing
that did look at okay well you have the
system you're not actually maybe you
perceive you're obliged to use it or you
don't perceive you're obliged to use it
we can measure it around and so I think
it's to your point yes we need to look
at the organization and an individual
isn't independent of that but I think
I'm interested in how the organizational
influence affects an individual's
decision that's kind of the main focus
but to your point I could also flip and
say how does an organization do it there
aren't any great models that I'm aware
of right now they're healthy
and I think we're out of time if you
have additional questions please email
Chris and we thank you all for coming
today
thank you
[Applause]